I worked for six years at the strategy
Consulting for McKinsey so what
distinguishes strong consultants in the
first years from those that do not
perform that well in the my humble
experience these are exactly four types
of skills so the first is communication
skills the second is slight writing
skills so can you create professional
documents the third is problem solving
skills and the fourth is professional
Readiness root firm learning it's my
mission to teach you exactly the skills
this is why I launched the
communications and slide Writing Academy
if you're interested to join this new
program leave me a comment and I will
get back to you